de jean gabin le vieux lyon avait joué
dans 93 fini élections législatives une
poussée du parti socialiste et un
maintien du dr identité de vues entre
paris et le caire sur le liban
le beaujolais en vente en france et en
angleterre l'arrivée de la première
bouteille à londres le goncourt a pas
très grave il pour les flamboyants
éditions du seuil
ma jeunesse j'ai voulu dire je sais
seulement plus chercher
et puis moi je savais
ya 60 coups qui ont sonné à l'horloge je
suis encore à ma fenêtre je regardais je
m'interroge
maintenant je sais je sais qu'on ne sait
jamais
la vie l'amour
l'argent les amis et les roses on ne
sait jamais le bruit ni la couleur des
choses c'est tout ce que je sais
message reçu mais là messieurs bonsoir
cette voie ce visage ces visages
il faut désormais les effacer du présent
alexis moncorgé est mort nous le
connaissions tous sous le nom de jean
gabin ce matin à l'hôpital américain de
neuilly il s'est éteint de sa belle mort
de vieillesse il avait 72 ans 72 ans et
on vous l'a dit 93 fils mercredi on va
l'enterrer je crois qu'on peut dire
comme jean paul belmondo qu'après
bourvil fernandel et michel simon c'est
le dernier grand monstre sacré du cinéma
français qui disparaît je crois qu'on
peut comprendre michel morvant quand
elle dit qu'il avait une façon si
naturelle de jouer qu'avec lui on ne
pouvait qu essayer d'être à sa hauteur
ont bien sûr il n'avait pas le caractère
bien commode bien sûr il gaby nizet il
en rajoutait sur son personnage mais
c'était quand même un sacré monument du
cinéma c'est un grand fauve bâti à chaud
et à sable mêmes vieux il se tient
encore mieux à table qu'à cheval c'est
énorme carcasse recèle toutes les
malignités dans l'acteur est capable il
reste le plus grand et le plus
fantastique véhicule du verbe
c'est le portrait de jean gabin fait par
pascal jardin romancier et scénariste
jean gabin le dur au coeur tendre du
cinéma français pouvait soutenir porter
n'importe quel rôle une centaine en un
demi siècle de carrière
pépé le moko de gens du vivier quai des
brumes de marcel carné la bête humaine
le clan des siciliens et avec renoir la
grande illusion en 1937 pour la parole
je ne bouge pas
marty français pensent aussi forte
avant les lis je leur dis comme ça
rex 4
price quote il faut c'est ce qu'a pu
dire quand même les chômeurs vers
seattle bendit des gendarmes et le
liechtenstein et le ce fret
quant au 11e round à l'elysée non non
non moi j'ai pas confiance on sait
clairement d'abord une progression
extraordinaire du parti socialiste
toutes les vedettes du cinéma français
se réclame de l'amité de jean gabin et
c'est pourtant une vieille dame son
habilleuse qui le connaissaient le mieux
quarante ans de travail en commun les 40
ans de complicité
il a été l usine il a fait des trucs que
vous connaissez c'est son père qu'elle
l'a poussé à pour aller pour aller
chanter quoi pour aller sur la scène de
la foule à coups pied dans le derrière
quoi comme vous et moi il m'avait dit je
trouvais pas ça naturel de faire ah non
il les met bas il avait une
il fallait qu'il se maquille mais on
peut pas dire qu'ils avaient du plaisir
à se remaquiller j'avais horreur de ça
d'ailleurs il avait horreur de ce qu'on
peut appeler les attouchements n'aimait
pas qu'on lui mette la main sur l'épaule
sont embrasés même époque on n'était pas
c'était pas lambin embrasseurs cette
époque les poignées de main il n'aimait
pas il aimait pas les contacts comme ça
ça ne vous plaisait pas
j'ai peur première dauphine vous êtes
plutôt une grande personne dans man au
nom de personnes chaque fois que
quelqu'un arrivait c'était pour lui
demander quelque chose c'est exaspérant
vous savez de comme vous voyez arriver
quelqu'un mais il savait bonjour tu vas
bien
et puis y apporte quelque chose pour moi
ou une demande de n'importe quoi alors
on dit c'est du mauvais call terminons
c'est c'est de l'autodéfense comprenez
vous que c'est plus facile de jouer la
comédie
moi par exemple j'ai l'air très détendu
je suis toujours tendu lui même voulait
toujours la perfection alors
naturellement c'était on disait il ne
parle pas et tout c'est une facilité
dans son métier dans sur un plateau il
était dans
dans son travail on était des heures
sans parler alors je lever le doigt zine
et on va pas paraît un peu bas pour
faire sur eparsa parlez pas à ce qui est
un silencieux mais je crois que ce qui
me plaisait dans moi justement c'était
que je ne bavarde est pas si j'avais pas
eu la cg de la sagesse de faire
attention de quand j'avais s'emballe
d'en dépenser 50 epide essayer d'en
mettre 40 à gauche
eh ben
jma économiquement faibles le chant
capin que tout le monde connaît c'est le
monstre sacré du cinéma
mais l'homme jean-alexis moncorgé était
profondément attaché à la terre et
l'essentiel pour lui était sans doute ce
domaine 220 hectares en normandie
acheté pour y vivre et élever des
chevaux sont nos terres savait que gabin
préféré sans doute ce métier à celui
d'acteur elle a bien écouté il était
dans la vie comme le tuto gil marin un
homme bourru mais un homme très humain
car très bon coeur moi je ne parlait
presque pas cinéma avec lui parce que je
ne voulais pas le fatiguer avec ça il
fait du rock se trouve désormais dans la
campagne je parlais de son élevage des
cultivateurs qu'il veut bien malgré ce
qu'on lui avait fait il ya une quinzaine
d'années est-ce qu'il avait été très
affecté par cette affaire il a été très
affecté
je le vis pleurer devant moi le jour
même l'après midi de cette affaire là on
l'avait accusé de cumuler un avec une
loi qui interdit le cumul monsieur cap
et n'a jamais perdu contre un
cultivateur et c'est toujours entendu
avec tout le monde à l'amiable
il n'a jamais eu un tracé ici avec des
cultivateurs jamais mais les gens ont
fini par l'admettre un buzz aux petits
s'il venait il vient souvent faire ses
courses traduction boire un pot café
mais si ça se trouve et il était
vraiment
adopté par le pays ici c'est finalement
c'était plus moncorgé que gabin oui
enfin je connaissais nous sommes une
bande de gamins moi c'était mais c'était
l'homme de la terre c'était l'homme de
200 élevages que nous connaissions un
point de vue cinéma tout le monde à
quatre heures de la voile en six films
on ne connaissait pas comme artistes ici
mais c'est son caractère son caractère
humain son caractère derrière de
laquelle il aimait la terre et je crois
je me trompe peut-être mais je crois
qu'il préférait être cultivateurs
qu'artiste
pour lui ça trappe la première
profession 7 et cultivateurs jean gabin
bourru fidèles monument du cinéma
français de jacques prévert cette
épitaphe l'acteur le plus solide et le
plus fragile en même temps sobre comme
le vin rouge simples comme la tâche de
sang et parfois gay comme le petit vin
blanc
bonne tenue de lui dr progression du ps
tassement des giscardiens effritement du
pc voilà en quelques mots tout est dit
sur les enseignements des sept élections
législatives partielles qui se sont
déroulées hier les résultats vous les
connaissez déjà un élu pour le ps et 2
pour lui d air reste donc quatre sièges
à pourvoir dimanche prochain avec une
inconnue la participation car comme
d'habitude en pareille circonstance il y
en a peu voté hier un électeur sur deux
seulement dans les yvelines par exemple
voilà pour les tendances générales
maintenant le détail des situations
circonscription par circonscription
succès personnel confortable pour
jacques chirac près de 54% des suffrages
exprimés mieux qu'aux dernières
élections législatives de 1973 le second
est le candidat communiste suivi de très
près par le candidat du parti socialiste
victoire plus surprenante de l'ue dr
jean tiberi dans le 5e arrondissement de
paris plus de 54% des voix le socialiste
devance le communiste et le candidat
écologiste recueille près de 7 % des
votes
en haute loire c'était le deuxième tour
de scrutin faut remplacer le docteur
simon décédé
le socialiste louis herrault candidat
unique de la gauche est élue de justesse
il bat le sénateur républicain
indépendant jean proriol 250 et une voix
ballottage en gironde il a manqué 153
voix à l'ancien secrétaire d'état ou
fait tt et mara chine foule pour être
élu dimanche prochain son adversaire
sera un radical de gauche
le docteur julien à vichy gabriel
perreault net en ballotage nette
augmentation des votes socialistes par
rapport à 1973 17 candidats communistes
qui est second derrière monsieur
peyronnet le républicain indépendant
gérard ducray est en ballotage difficile
dans la 10e circonscription du rhône
augmentation de plus de 14% des voix
socialistes
bénard destremeau républicains
indépendants est également en position
difficile très net progrès des
socialistes et de la gauche dont le
candidat dimanche sera jean cuguen
communiste arrivé en tête hier on sait
clairement d'abord une progression
extraordinaire du parti socialiste on le
dit sans arrêt de partiel en sondages et
en cantonales c'est confirmé ça ne
s'arrête pas c'est le parti socialiste
qui progressent et il progresse tous
azimuts donc il prend effectivement une
partie de ses veaux parti communiste qui
s'effrite
sauf dans l'allier dans les yvelines où
il tient bien mais ailleurs le pcc
frites et ses voies vont sans doute
parti socialiste mais pour l'essentiel
les gains socialiste ne se font pas là
ils se font probablement sur les
électeurs centristes qui était centriste
d'opposition jusqu'à 74 et qui
n'acceptent pas leur alignement de leur
chef au giscardisme qui préfèrent voter
pour le ps c'est du théâtre en partie
aussi à des électeurs nouveaux électeurs
de 18 à 21 ans qui vote pour la première
fois je crois que grosso modo 8 sur 10
des succès du ps sont des électeurs
centristes ou des jeunes électeurs
et puis 2 sur 10 tout de même aussi les
électeurs communistes autrefois alors
côté majorité c'est une victoire de
lutter contre les républicains
indépendants
c'est une des façons de voir les choses
c'est très difficile de savoir les
motivations des électeurs
on peut dire c'est évident de lui d r
c'est clair que les deux candidats eu
des airs chirac
tiberi réussissent brillamment on peut
se demander aussi si une des raisons du
succès ne tient pas dans l'implantation
ses candidats
ce sont des députés qui ont bien fait
leur travail au parlement qui ont tissé
patiemment des réseaux de notables des
réseaux de personnes qui travaillent
pour eux de militants peut-être que
l'implantation c'est aussi du clé du
succès c'est vrai pour lui d r c'est
vrai pour le candidat communiste dans
les yvelines
peut-être qu'on oublie un peu trop qu'un
travail de député à travail de candidats
ça se prépare aussi y'a pas que les
étiquettes qui joue mais aussi
l'implantation personnel puis une fois
n'est pas coutume alors que
traditionnellement chaque parti
politique tire à lui la couverture du
succès au lendemain d'élections et
aujourd'hui les deux parties dans le
vent lui dr lps sont relativement
modestes du dr se contente de parler de
la force mobilisatrice de son mouvement
et le ps de la progression significative
de son score les questions c'était doko
perdant qu'il fallait les poser peremans
provisoire où nous verrons bien au
deuxième tour pour les riz et pour les
communistes
ces résultats ne nous inquiète pas il
nous semble qu'il faut encore beaucoup
faire avancer dans la population
chez les travailleurs en particulier
l'idée que pour que la gauche gagne pour
que les changements véritables que nous
proposons à notre peuple avec en
particulier de la mise en oeuvre de la
politique du programme commun par un
gouvernement de gauche où les par les
communistes participeraient eh bien il
nous faut encore convaincre encore
beaucoup pour que ils ces travailleurs
ressentent la nécessité d'un parti
communiste fort et influent
les élections de son pain un test
national
ce sont des élections partielles ou la
personnalité du candidat joue beaucoup
mais vous dites ne connaissons pas bien
maintenue pas du tout mais monsieur
ducret et a retrouvé très exactement le
pourcentage de voix qu'il avait faite en
1900 aux dernières élections et
formateur de 18 et bien nous verrons
second tour au second au premier tour en
il avait exactement le pourcentage le
réformateur à l'époque je sache n'était
pas dans la majorité il était à
l'extrait la majorité proriol bon
proriol a été battu il était battu deux
sens
n'est ce pas à deux cent voix et je
constate aussi que dans cette
circonscription
ce dans un mouchoir on ne peut pas dire
que vraiment ce soir l'élection de test
donc ça c'était hier soir nous referons
une pareille émission spéciale à 21h30
dimanche prochain vous le voyez aussi
bien dans la majorité dans l'opposition
les partis veulent pas paraître
solidaires de leurs partenaires même si
ce matin sur europe 1 michel poniatowski
évoqué deux rassemblements au sein de la
majorité
l'un autour de jacques chirac et puis
l'autre autour de démocratie française
autrement dit dans l'ombre du président
la république
ce clivage on retrouve dans le cas
particulier des municipales à paris
vous le savez valéry giscard d'estaing a
pressenti michel d'ornano comme candidat
de la majorité
réponse du groupe eu des airs du conseil
de paris ni oui ni non
réponse de jacques dominati qui a mis sa
déception dans sa poche
il est très compétent il faut l'aider et
puis aussi réponse définitive de michel
d'ornano
comme il fallait s'y attendre si oui
j'avais demandé un délai de réflexion
après cette désignation
étant donné les fonctions municipales et
départementales que j'occupe j'ai
utilisé cette fin de semaine a procédé
aux consultations locales qui était
nécessaire et je viens de faire savoir
par lettre à monsieur olivier guichard
qui m'avait communiqué la lettre du
premier ministre que j'acceptais la
mission qui m'était confiée en
accomplissant la tâche qui m'a été
confiée au nom de la majorité
eh bien je m'efforcerai d'apporter à
paris au parisien l'expérience que je
peux avoir de la gestion gestion dans
l'entreprise d'abord gestion municipale
ensuite et gestion dans un ministère
important enfin ceci encore dans une
actualité politique très chargé les
chiffres des demandeurs d'emplois pour
octobre
ils ne sont pas bons du tout le cap du
million est à nouveau franchi 1 millions
et 25 mille trois cent 300 demandes une
journée d'action de la cgc aujourd'hui
sur la fiscalité la même chose pour la
cgt avec la fiscalité est aussi la
sécurité sociale
une déclaration à l'assemblée de maurice
ligot le gouvernement maintient pour les
fonctionnaires le principe de la
négociation des salaires en 77 une
déclaration est destiné à désamorcer un
petit peu la grogne des amis dans
l'engagement
maurice rigaud et s'apprête à d'état à
la fonction publique et puis toujours à
l'assemblée mais demain la discussion du
budget de la radio de télévision un
budget qui nous intéresse au premier
chef vous et nous vous comme
téléspectateurs nous comme journaliste
écoutons ce qu'en dit son rapporteur
joël le tac satisfait la gestion des
chaînes mais moins tendre sur la qualité
des programmes
quand je dis que j'ai vu pendant trop
longtemps une série du series américaine
de basse classe enfin d'une scierie b et
que nous avons tous vécu sur un acquis
qui était déjà fortement épuisé
je pense qu'on a tout de même été vers
une solution de facilité qu'on n'a pas
démarré assez vite les problèmes de
création est ce que vous pensez
globalement que la télévision actuelle
est moins bonne que celle du temps de
rtf oui fatalement et les moins bonnes
il a fallu veut nous prendre la réforme
de 1974 un débouché sur évidemment deux
trois années contre tous qualifiés d
c'est tout de même le galop d'essai et
elle est fatalement moins bonne puisque
de même le loup rtf avait engrangé à
certains l'avouent regret c'est le temps
du rpr je ne regrette pas le rtf en soi
puisque l'on martèle c'était une
organisation monstrueuse irresponsable
et hiérarchisé aveuglément et où le
courant ne passait plus ne s'agit pas de
recréer le rtf
on sait que la concurrence est excessive
je crois qu'elle est excessive puisque
elle débouche sur une recherche
d'audience systématique et fatalement au
détriment de la qualif il qu'est ce que
vous attendez
globalement de la télévision dans
l'année qui va suivre
mais je crois je suit montrait optimiste
qu'il faut pas non plus couvrir la tête
de cendres je crois que timide parce que
je sais je les grâces d'ailleurs à ces
deux derniers jours j'ai appris que
beaucoup de projets étaient en cours
aussi bien à tf1 car antenne 2 et qui me
semble tout à fait propice à l'esprit
création je pense qu'après deux années
une année d'intense une année blanche
plus une année un peu de cafouillage il
faut le dire nous aurons peut-être à feu
d'artifice
vous avez cité antenne 2 ici et ailleurs
d'ailleurs on a parfois l'impression
quand n 2 est une chaîne un petit peu
mal comprises est souvent critiquée il
n'est pas un animal comprise ni mallet
mais il ne faut pas faire de complexe
antenne 2 est une chaîne avec qui a le
visage un peu de son président c'est à
dire qu'à une grande gaieté une grande
sensibilité qui souffre quand on attaque
et je crois qu'il ya quelque chose de sa
parfums discrets d'une certaine
bourgeoisie de rive gauche qui est assez
sympathique et hassen chaudement
conformisme c'est sa voix léger non
conformisme ça ne vous inquiète pas non
conformisme l'antique via une forme de
confort missions les plus importants
merci monsieur le rapporteur
c'est un spectacle étonnant qu a connues
beyrouth aujourd'hui des chars ont
quadrillé la ville 250 chars sont entrés
dans beyrouth et la population a clamé
sa joie les chars en effet étaient ceux
des casques verts des forces syriennes
si vous voulez qu'ils ont pénétré dans
la ville la rose au poing alors les
libanais un peu éberlués un peu soulagé
après 19 mois de guerre impitoyable
les libanais sont sortis dollars avec
des fleurs et casques verts s'est ouvert
avec leurs chars et leurs camions
appelés centres commerciaux dans les
régions peut trouver votre soir dans
l'église et un chrétien
c'est pourtant ce plaisir que la
population mi-août dans la capitale
libanaise à présent des soldats syriens
les quartiers des combats les places et
les bâtiments publics aux papiers que la
vie normale pour un repas
l'autre s'y rallier le liban précisément
l'un des thèmes majeurs des
entretiendrait mon bar avec anouar
el-sadate anouar el sadate dont vous
allez entendre en quelques secondes les
indians ont recueillies par notre
correspondant au caire pierre serra à
montbard avec ce nouvel entretien
achever son voyage il y tient sa
première visite officielle à l'étranger
son avion va se poser à paris dans moins
de deux heures et à 23 heures
le compte rendu de voyage de notre
envoyé spécial philippe harrouard voici
donc comme promis
lyn thériault du premier ministre
égyptien a enregistré quelques heures
avant son entrée en lice sur le problème
du liban nous avons la france et
l'egypte une position commune et je dois
dire ici que j'ai trouvé valéry giscard
d'estaing d'une grande aide et d'une
très grande compréhension gare pour tous
les problèmes il avait une solution
précise everywhere votre édito el al
assad après le sommet arabe du caire qui
s'est déroulée il ya quelques semaines
j'ai envoyé à mon ami le président
giscard d'estaing un rapport complet sur
tout ce qui s'était passé ici h et ce
dialogue qui s'est déroulé dans les
relations harmonieuses que je vous ai
décrites plus haut
ouf la qualité des rapports que nous
avons avec la france
nous avons été retardés dans la
recherche d'une paix globale au proche
orient
car 1976 a été l'année de l'élection
américaine
alors nous espérons que l'année 1977
avec l'arrivée de carter au pouvoir sera
l'année d'une nouvelle conférence de
genève qui devrait apporter une solution
au conflit du moyen-orient
autres visites à l'étranger celle que
françois ceyrac le président du patronat
français vient de faire en chine
françois ceyrac conduisait tout une
délégation du cnpf
de plus en plus en effet les patrons
français s'intéressent à ce vaste marché
marché presque vierge encore et ce
malgré les incertitudes politiques liées
à l'après mao c'est un marché dès
aujourd'hui de 900 millions d'habitants
peut-être d'un milliard l'an 2000
c'est donc un des grands marchés du
monde la france depuis 1950 peu 55
après un très grand effort elle n'est
pas mal placé
le grand problème c'est d'améliorer de
renforcer notre situation dans les
années qui viennent
est ce que par exemple les chinois sont
intéressés par le métro par des procédés
de télévision qui sont exactement ce qui
intéresse les chinois dans la panoplie
l'industrie française l'intérêt pour eux
ce sont les techniques de pointe
or nous leur avons prouvé une fois de
plus que la france dans ce domaine est
bien placé et chaque fois que nous ont
pu leur montrer que les techniques
français nous les vendions aussi aux
grands pays capitalistes y compris
l'amérique nous avons retenu l'attention
du chiffre il n'y a pas un risque pour
nous pays déjà industrialisés à aider un
pays comme la chine à s'industrialiser
je veux dire un risque de concurrence
c'est un risque qu'il irait tellement
général et qu' il nous présente j'ai
drap plus de danger le monde entier est
en voie d'industrialisation les pays du
tiers monde la chine et je pense que
c'est l'amélioration de la situation du
monde antique est importante nous
commerçons avec des pays très
industrialisés la moitié de notre
commerce international se fait avec
l'allemagne par conséquent le voisinage
un pays très industrielle il n'empêche
pas les échanges il faut effectivement
progressivement reconsidérer le problème
des échanges dans le monde entier et ne
peuvent pas avoir peur de l'arrivée au
niveau industriel de grande unité comme
la chine de demain une accolade tito
brejnev à belgrade voilà une photo
histoire il ya un quart de siècle
pareil amitié soviéto yougoslave n'était
pas imaginable le pain un marshal tito
venait d'être alors exclu par l'urss de
l'organisation qui regroupait les pays
communistes
sidéré comme un traître alors
qu'aujourd'hui le voyage de leonid
brejnev en yougoslavie consacre la
totale normalisation des rapports entre
les deux pays et il est évident que
moscou de plus en plus entend consolider
ses relations avec les autres états
socialiste avant l'installation de jimmy
carter à washington on l'a constaté avec
la chine
on le constate aujourd'hui avec la
yougoslavie ou l'accueil à aller ni de
brejnev était quand même assez réservé
la yougoslavie constitue depuis 28 ans
une sorte d'état tampon entre l'occident
et le bloc soviétique pays non-alignés
la yougoslavie n'a pu conserver sa
relative indépendance que grâce dans un
premier temps à l'aide américaine à
commencer par le plan marshall et si
l'urss ne s'y est pas opposé comme elle
l'a fait dès 1948 avec la
tchécoslovaquie
c'est à cause de la forte personnalité
de tito aujourd'hui tito à 84 ans les
américains se retirent progressivement
nous ne nous battront pas pour la
yougoslavie a même lancé
jimmy carter durant sa campagne
électorale en quatre ans l'urss est
devenue le premier client est le premier
fournisseur de la yougoslavie son aide
technique est importante
pays pauvre 1 des revenus par tête les
plus bas de l'europe
un allemand de l'est par exemple vos
trois yougoslave à cet égard voici donc
la yougoslavie qui entrent dans la
dépendance économique du bloc soviétique
de la dépendance économique à la
soumission politique la distance se
mesure-t-elle pour ce pays au nombre de
mois qu'il reste à tito à vivre on peut
se poser la question
d'autant que champion de l'indépendance
nationale le vieux maréchal est aussi le
garant de l'unité de son pays
une unité bien fragile du fait des
nombreux peuples qui le constituent ce
pays un pays divisé est toujours plus
facile à sous mais voilà ce qui se
profile derrière cette visite de brejnev
à belgrade
la première d'un dirigeant soviétique
depuis dix ans
la terre a de nouveau tremblé en chine
l'épicentre du séisme se situe à
quelques centaines de kilomètres de
pékin le séisme d'aujourd'hui est
comparable à celui du 28 juillet dernier
qui va et fait de très nombreuses
victimes
cette fois encore une grande partie de
la population de pékin s'est précipité
dans les rues sans panique tous
s'apprêtent à passer la nuit dehors
une nuit froide on craint de nouvelles
secousses ce tremblement de terre a été
enregistré à l'institut de physique du
globe de strasbourg avec l'amplitude 7
sur l'échelle de richter
le président du conseil du gouvernement
de djibouti monsieur de la cam il a eu
45 minutes d'entretien avec le président
giscard d'estaing à l'elysée cet
entretien avait pour but de préparer le
référendum sur l'indépendance qui se
déroulera au printemps prochain
pour monsieur camille l'issue du
référendum ne fait pas de doute ce sera
l'indépendance mais ce n'est qu'avec
l'accord du gouvernement français
qu'elle sera proclamé monsieur camus il
a précisé que cette indépendance sera
sans restriction vis-à-vis de la france
et des états voisins notamment de la
somalie
coupe du monde
on connaît la composition de l'équipe de
france de football qui rencontrera
l'irlande du sud mercredi soir au parc
des princes deux changements chez les
français par rapport à la formation qui
a joué contre la bulgarie
rocheteau on retrouve son poste d'ailier
droit et kerusore de laval jouera au
milieu du terrain
le sélectionneur a donc préféré kerusore
à santini
mais sans doute le capitaine stéphanois
fera son apparition en cours de partie
contre les irlandais match retransmis en
direct sur antenne 2 à partir de 20h30
15 novembre c'est le jour du concours
c'est aussi le jour du beaujolais du
beaujolais nouveau
ne vous méprenez pas trop d r moi c'est
bien jimmy carter qui est en train de
boire notre beaujolais mais la photo
date d'il ya quatre ans le beaujolais
nouveau cette année n'a pas encore eu le
temps de franchir l'atlantique en
revanche il a déjà franchi la manche
à l'issue d'un pari d'un concours vous
allez le voir c'est cocasse
les jeux sont faits pour les beaujolais
primeur et tout va bien les prix ont
monté 20% environ
mais en quelques semaines les 170 mille
hectolitres que représente cette récolte
primeur 76 seront écoulés les français
votent en boire la moitié est dans
l'ordre les suisses les allemands les
belges et les anglais l'autre moitié ce
vin frais privilégie la région
beaujolaise par rapport aux autres
régions viticoles françaises
pas de frais de stockage et le vigneron
encaissent rapidement de l'argent alors
que le vin n'est resté qu'un court
moment dans s'excuse traditionnellement
sur le 15 novembre à minuit selon
autorise la vente du beaujolais c'est
une sécurité pour le consommateur et la
nuit dernière la traduction était
respectée vers toute l'europe des
voitures des camions prêt à partir à
l'heure h piot n'en sont en baisse en
raison principalement du fait de la
différence du taux des changes
m'ayant une chose curieuse quand même il
faut bien l'admettre c'est que les
projets de grande qualité sont toujours
en augmentation trouve partout dans la
grande restauration au niveau de
consommateurs qui cherchent vraiment
d'avoir des vins de qualité
dès qu'on bouge les déboulés de qualité
est là les anglais sont malgré le taux
des chances tout à fait d'accord pour
payer une prime pour les avoir vous êtes
deux femmes pour conduire son camion
pourquoi pas c'est un camion qui
transporte combien de tonnes de
beaujolais c'est énorme
nous savons en à 1100 watts et oui parmi
tous les coureurs miss troc miss camion
76 en angleterre avec pour co pilote
une autre femme sur le trajet mâcon
londres et bien sûr le plus rapidement
possible au volant de leurs 38 tonnes
ces deux demoiselles anglaises ont
réussi une belle performance mâcon
calais à la moyenne de 90 km heure elles
sont arrivées à londres avant les
voitures particulières pour mettre le
beaujolais à la disposition des amateurs
britanniques
je vais 76
ben est excellent nous sommes très
contents ils te gallo 69 auquel vais
vraiment avec plaisir voir cette
couverture est déjà périmé il faut tjrs
arracher la bande annonce et la
remplacer par une autre plus commerciale
prix goncourt 76 c'est en effet patrick
grainville un jeune professeur qui n'a
même pas la trentaine qui vient de
remporter un prix déjà sa portée les
années précédentes
son titre les flamboyants les
flamboyants ces arbres tropicaux dubé
rang qui symbolise c'est bien cette
aventure baroque et l'âge lit le verso
de la page de couverture du livre
les événements se précipitent au rythme
de cette image du feu du sang et de tous
les désirs le prix goncourt 1976 est
attribuée au roman intitulé les
flamboyants le pas très grave il au
troisième tour par cinq voix contre deux
a gêné la folle
vignès cagnati et une voix au loup
cervier de geek rossi et voilà le projet
de patrick grainville est arrivé on
pouvait s'attendre à son succès car sa
maison d'édition le seuil était
largement représentée au sein du jury
mais aujourd'hui le goncourt est plus
une bataille entre éditeurs qu'entre
écrivain mais au seuil qu'on feint la
surprise les premières bandes avec la
mention glorieuse goncourt 1976 où
paraît-il été commandé à 13h et déjà
deux heures après on coupe et on colle
dans l'euphorie patrick grainville à 29
ans il a le goncourt et c'est peut-être
un fardeau lourd à porter
quand elle boncourt de sécurité et ont
pu écrire avec mon angoisse moines peur
pour l'avenir
vous croyez ça parce qu'avant le
goncourt à 29 ans maintenant on va vous
jugé encore plus sévèrement
et oui mais il ya une espèce de je suis
content que les flamboyants et le
goncourt parce que c'est le roman que je
préfère alors je gère autant que ça soit
fixé sur les flamboyants et puis comme
j'ai une espèce d'obsession qu'elle
baroque génial et arthur baroque
littérature dans les aventures baroque
et grand paysage baroque et j'ai pouvoir
je l'avais un espèce de moyen d'audience
pour en parler que j'avais pas jusqu'ici
tu dois en parler défendre les couleurs
baroques
parce qu'en france il semble qu'ils
m'aiment que le le prix
elle sera donnée à littérature classique
roman psychologique intérieur les 15
qu'il très dépouillée j'aime plutôt une
dictature extraverti man exhibitionnisme
littérature qui se donne et qui se prend
des risques ce casse la figure qui
repart je préfère ça alors cessibles
défendre ça comme il ya un courant l
aventure dans le roman et que je parle
beaucoup des paysages de la terre du feu
de l'eau du végétal est atteint il ya un
an nos politiques à plus inattendu je
crois qu'il est porté par l' aventure
c'est moins gênant c'est que c'est pas
un roman qui fait pour les mots et je
crois que dans le roman c'était les mots
qui était fait pour l' aventure tout le
même vous qui aimez bien manier les mots
clés le mot de la langue française que
vous détestez le plus un mot que je
déteste moi je ne sais pas le mot je
déteste le plus est française
anticonstitutionnellement ça se savait
déteste ça nos félicitations à l'heureux
vainqueur félicitations aussi aux prix
renaudot michel henry pour l'amour les
yeux fermés les yeux fermés par dont
michel henry est lui aussi professeur
professeur d'université les philosophes
il a 54 ans son roman à la particularité
nous dit on ne se situe à une époque
indéterminée dans une ville imaginaire
voilà nous arrivons à la fin de ce
journal journal plus longue d'habitude
en raison de l'abondance de l'actualité
comme chaque soir maintenant la météo
demain enfin du soleil sur la
méditerranée des nuages en bretagne en
normandie est partout et ailleurs de
faibles pluies
il fera assez froide matin avec des
gelées locales fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir écouté jusqu'au bout au nom
de tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à le
préparer à vous le présenter je vous
souhaite à tous une excellente soirée
mais tout de suite le rappel des titres
jean gabin est mort ce matin poussé
socialiste maintient de l'ue dr la
france au proche orient
le goncourt a patrie graville le
renaudot à michel henry dernier journal
d'antenne 2 à 23h35